[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are once and for all
definitively
settling your arguments your disputes
that you're having with your loved ones
your friends your family your you know
people in your life things that you need
help
things that you need these two
dads
decided to settle for you dads well i
mean we i'm so many things to so many
people right what is the thing you think
gives you the most
like
legitimacy in giving advice
being a father i'm being a business
owner being a lifelong friend
being a decent driving a wannabe
hairstylist as long as i'm not in a deep
conversation
yeah i think i'm a decent driver well
but typically when i'm driving with you
we are in a deep conversation so my
experience is that okay i'm not
qualified you almost killed one of our
fans but i do and you had to find out
later through instagram well they
shouldn't have been crossing the street
in front of me
um
i i like these episodes because uh
it's you know it just brings up
things about us that we can just project
onto other people
i thought you were going to say that you
like giving advice
i like giving it back i know that about
it makes me feel
makes me feel helpful
i think you think i like it for another
reason but i just want to be helpful
what i wait don't project anything on me
every time you say that i like giving
advice
it's as if you're judging me like it be
honest like you do not think it's a good
thing that i love i like giving people
advice
i'm sorry that i like to help people no
no i'm just i'm saying that
i can sense when someone is about to
fall into it
like when there's someone who's in the
room with us or somebody that we just
met
and i'm like oh no no no you're about to
oh what you just said now you've done it
you've pulled the advice trigger and
you're about to get it from link i mean
it's like i'm not saying you don't you
give bad advice i'm just saying it's
just an observation i've made it's a
funny thing like there's lots of funny
things about people that make them
eccentric one of the things about you is
that you really like to give advice
i i
i just i can't help it if i care about
people
okay i'm not saying i don't like giving
advice now i don't think
highly of myself and i do try to couch
my advice hey it's just food for thought
you need it
you you're not asking for advice you say
yeah yeah you're not asking for it what
are you one of your catchphrases you
didn't ask me this you didn't ask for
this you're not actually asking for
advice but i am ready for it to give it
to you yeah yeah yeah and i think that
does it if i thought it was a bad idea i
wouldn't think that this was a good idea
for an episode usually i say
i mean you're not you're not asking for
advice here but and then they'll cut me
off and say oh no no i want to i want to
hear your input and if they don't say
that
then i'm like i'm gonna i'm gonna hold
back a little bit
so i i have adjusted in that way you put
it on them to tell you to stop i mean i
wouldn't stop if somebody that i don't
know well i can tell starts to give
advice to me nobody tell them unless
they break in and say oh no i i want to
hear unless they say that i'm not going
to go full force i'm not going to give
them like the whole the blunt
but you're going to go full force today
because these people have asked for us
to go full force exactly
but i have i need one for everybody i
need to go full force in something else
yes you do because this is something
i've been dying to tell you about i know
the party
the premiere night before last
so
we get invited and you know for years we
went to these occasions and of course
something called a pandemic happened so
we haven't been to one of these but we
get invited to these premieres for
whether it's a movie or a tv show we
don't go to many of them but there was
one that was falling on
me and jesse's date night
and i was like oh this will be fun like
get back out in the world and go to a
premiere sit in a room with people and
watch a show and go to a party
and the personal connection this was the
we were invited too but christy and i
couldn't go yeah so the the show uh is
upload on amazon prime
our connection to the show is that it's
made by greg daniels who you may know as
the creator of the office one of the
best comedies of all time
the american office yep yes so yeah
exactly which is definitively if you're
you didn't ask for advice but i'll give
you definitively better there's that one
better than the british version um
i love ricky gervais why am i even
getting into that but uh
so greg daniels and he is the husband of
suzanne daniels who was for like six or
seven years the head of original
programming at youtube youtube originals
so we got to know her through the
development of buddy system and also
uh the expanded format of good mythical
morning she's
she's just a great person i love suzanne
daniels she's very sweet she's always
been an advocate of us very smart she
was at the uh the streamies
when we won show of the year and she
stood up at her table and gave us a
standing ovation at her table i mean she
really believed in us that was very kind
so i was hoping i would get to see that
night that we met uh greg yeah
and their son who you said is a star
yeah so owen
who plays the
uh like bell boy essentially in this
the premise of the show is that when you
die you
uh your consciousness is uploaded to an
afterlife where you like live at this
hotel
and
uh he plays the bell boy who's
essentially ai and he's he's him but
also many versions of him
now we remember we met owen
uh when he interviewed us for some
youtube show he was doing he was like 16
years old at the time that was at a
stream he's way way back in the day yeah
and
yeah and now he and he was actually
involved in the creative process on the
show
uh with greg
and then yeah he's he's one of the stars
so he was there i got to talk to him
nepotism
but but what happened he's very talented
but what happened so uh just a joke one
of the things uh
that you do when you go to these
premieres is you walk the red carpet now
typically what would happen if
uh link and i went with jesse and
christy
um
you and i would want the red carpet yeah
they've never you know they're not like
itching to walk the red carpet with us
but it was like i'm going just with me
and jesse and i was like hey you can you
know if you want to walk the red carpet
with me
i you know whatever you want to do i'll
go by myself you can walk with me she
says i'll walk with you yeah let's do it
so
you know when you arrive at these things
you get you sort of meet your contact
person who takes you to the line and
then you stand there in the line and you
get ready to walk through and then that
person tells the people who you are who
invites you writes your name on so that
you don't have to tell people who you
are because that is really demoralizing
yeah
and so why am i taking your picture
who yes another good mystical what
so the uh
i thought that he might be there because
of his tie to to uh to greg daniels but
i really wasn't expecting it but i'm in
the sort of the line getting ready to go
on the red carpet and none other than
conan o'brien and his wife
uh walk up and of course
they kind of had me in the line getting
ready to get onto the red carpet when
conan o'brien shows up somebody comes up
to him and says you come to the front of
the line
but as he was passing me you know i did
something that wasn't typical of me you
tripped him
why but but because you aren't there
because you would have done this if you
were there i was like well link's not
here so i guess i have to do this uh he
walked by i was like conan
rhett shook his hand he was like oh good
to see you now this could just be the
pat answer that he gives to anyone who
says obviously is trying to say
something like you know me i was on your
show 11 years ago
maybe you've kept up with us maybe you
have and i haven't spoken with you in
years good for you to give the emphatic
conan rhett yeah so i should shake exp
and then he's going to just move on yeah
yeah and then he's moved on yeah the
good news is is a as he moved up to the
red carpet then my
pr person came up and was like oh you
come now we're ready for you and so i
got to go right after conan so it kind
of looked like
maybe i was important for a moment okay
you know
maybe andy richter grew his hair out and
got tall and uh so we go through like
you know you you you do the thing you
walk and you because jesse was like well
what because she hadn't done this i i
did or he doesn't remember when she was
like what do i do i was like they're
just gonna like this there's gonna be a
bunch of cameras and the person's gonna
be like rhett jesse
and you're gonna look at that person
with that camera and you're gonna smile
and then the next person says hey over
here and you're gonna just do that right
it's called a step and repeat for a
reason yeah and so we did that it went
great i think the pictures turned out
great
you can probably find them on the
internet somewhere
uh jessie helped me pick that sweater it
sort of matches her dress
we were pretty proud of ourselves um
she made me change let me just be
completely honest i put on a a a shirt
and she said there's not i have do not
have that color in my dress oh and then
i looked into the drawer and i was like
well this sweater almost looks just like
your dress and she was like i think this
may be too much i was like well i'm only
changing once and so i wore it and it
ended up being great because multiple
people came up and said i love this
ensemble ensemble
so
we go through you guys should make
curtains we go through that then uh
i see that conan and his wife are
talking to suzanne i'm like perfect
opportunity to go back up and re-engage
so i go up there and i say hey suzanne i
give her a big hug i'm like you remember
my wife and then i shake because we love
conan and so your desire is to
have a little exchange because hey we
were on a show
i mean
we got a lot of respect for the guy and
so to like have a have an end to be able
to have a conversation
and to feel like acquaintances after all
we haven't spoken directly with him in a
while but some of our folks on the
mythical team have talked to some of his
folks at his production company for
years like you know just they know each
other as well so i don't know how much
he's involved in that but i was like
well let's just see i mean suzanne going
up and giving a big hug to suzanne and
her obviously knowing you this well
maybe that'll even be even
you know maybe he'll it'll start to
click if he doesn't remember who i am
who knows
i shake his wife's hand
and then i say to conan i said i say i'm
not going to shake your hand again
because i've already done it
and then he said well and he holds his
hand he says i'm going to shake your
hand again because it means that much to
me
so we shake as a so the power dynamics
you shake hands again you lost good um
then suzanne and really starts engaging
with me and jesse
he's a little taller than you he's like
no no he's not
do you think he's talk six seven i'm not
proud of being sick i guess i was saying
he's older than [ __ ] he's not
i mean that's i'm freaking in my mind
he's taller than you like you're not
tall not you're not that tall very tall
he might be six five i don't know he's
very tall yeah so
um the conversation shifts to suzanne
kind of catching up with her a little
bit uh
conan and his wife sort of peel off a
little bit yup so i was like that's cool
i'm catching up with suzanne
so then we grab a little glass of
champagne that they had and a popcorn
and go you know they always got their
little lean things and you go and we sit
we have assigned seats and we go and we
sit down
small little screening room at this
hotel in in west hollywood i don't know
there's probably
75 people there theater seating no
theater seating
and i sit down
and at this point and only this point
do i realize
that my fly is open
huh
[Laughter]
and and i don't mean red carpet i don't
let me look back at those red carpet
photos i don't mean like a third of the
way down oh yeah i mean like
the zipper was never engaged oh it was a
new pair of pants that i've never put on
and it had a weird three buttons at the
top oh yeah once you get you're
exhausted by the time you do that
i was all the buttons are done and it
was just like i had done too many things
to that portion of my
uh wardrobe and and forgot that there
was something else to be done which is
called zipping up the zipper now were
you wearing underwear
no i was free balling oh yeah and now
we're gonna do it so i was wearing
underwear yes
but at that point
like i'm thinking
oh man the first thing i thought was
i'm gonna talk about this on air
biscuits like they did that's that's the
life that i live yeah that's the re
that's the red that was literally the
first thing the second thing was life's
low points become entertainment what if
this is capture like was this captured
in all those
photos that i just took like literally
like 20 photographers took pictures
photographers did you get that blood
leaving your head and going to your like
feet or was it the opposite like you're
all the blow went to your face i didn't
get
it's interesting i didn't get a sinking
feeling because i was like man if
there's pictures a bunch of pictures of
me on the red carpet with the unzipped
fly like i'm in the profession where
this is something to be embraced it's
like it'll be a great story
i i wasn't
freaking out yeah i was just like
so
i
internet comedians are people too at
that point
i
when i realized it i zipped it up but
then i was like well hold on i got to
figure out
if this could be seen because maybe
these pants didn't show that the fly was
unzipped some pants
kind of bunch out and some don't you
know you
pants your pants and they're different
yeah yep so i stand up and now people
are filing into this premiere it's about
half full i stand up
and i
unzip my pants just kind of like
privately like unzip my pants and then
look at look at them and then zip them
back up and i'm like i don't
i don't know if you can see this and
then it hits me you're six foot seven
you're st you're in a theater you stand
up you unzip your pants
i'm pretty sure people are well i'm not
done
because at that point i'm like this is
something i should talk to conan about
he's like and i didn't i wasn't letting
i think it has something to do with not
being in public a lot you know over the
pandemic i think my dynamic has changed
okay yeah i didn't it didn't cross my
mind that this might not be a good idea
to go up to conan and his wife
yeah you weren't there and so i did all
the dumb stuff uh so
no it's not always college time so well
just wait so they're sitting down and
suzanne is now talking to them again
while they're sitting down
they're kind of like four or five rows
back
i get up i leave my seat i walk over i
walk down the road they're talking and i
kind of just go out there and i'm like
something just happened to me that i
think you would appreciate and conan
said whoa
conan said well i'll be the judge of
that
i mean he's always got something he's
always ready with a quip right
and then i said oh you
you left your seat
yeah that's what i said you walked out
of the aisle you walked back up
and went down another aisle there was
nobody sitting on the aisle yeah it
wasn't like i was like excuse me excuse
me excuse me i need to get a conan it
wasn't that okay he wasn't like that
he was accessible but you still had like
you already seated you had to get up
this is a big moment for you like i
can't believe you did this yeah i'm
telling you i'm just i changed you stood
up you you you went back and basically
like took over a conversation you were
like
like i'm gonna like a presentation here
i've got something
that i want to tell you
exactly so
uh i walk up to
to them and i say i've got something
that just happened to me that i think
you'll appreciate conan says we'll be
the judge of that and i said i just
realized that i did the entire red
carpet
with my fly down
and i didn't get the response i was
after um
all of them just kind of looked at me
like no they didn't you thought there
was a it wasn't immediate laughter and
and then they were like well and then i
said and this is where this is where it
really gets awkward i said keep going i
don't
know if it was a problem or not
and at that moment
standing up i'm standing up in front of
conan and his wife who are sitting down
i unzip my pants in front of them
i'm in the middle of the theater i am
i was proud of you i am uncomfortable
i unzipped my pants and i said and i go
and i hold my arms up like this and his
wife says you can't tell
oh good like she just gives me like just
gives it to me straight good you can't
tell and i'm like okay
and then i zip my pants back up and i
just walk back to my seat that was it
that's the interaction
you can't tell
uh suzanne didn't say anything
conan didn't say anything i think she
just kind of like she sort of smiled in
agreement i think they all just agreed
you can't tell since that seems to be
what you were asking
jessie did not come with you no she
didn't thankfully and i have no idea
what the conversation was after i went
and sat back down because you weren't
there anymore right uh i i immediately
regretted it when i went back to jesse
and i said i just went up to conan and
his wife who were seated and i was
standing right next to him and i just
unzipped my pants in front of them
you could be arrested for that everyone
else behind them i mean yeah this is not
i'm not proud
i'm not proud of this public exposure if
something were to be exposed it would
have been exposure i just now remembered
he did say something i
i i i mean i i i mean it's a little
traumatic
this is what conan said
i his wife said you can't tell and then
conan said
it would be a real problem if you stuck
your finger out there
like that that's
that's what that's what he said he says
as long as you don't you didn't get in
there and stick your finger out you're
okay
and so did you think about doing that to
test it nope i didn't because there's
three buttons i couldn't get my hand in
my pants if i wanted to
so
then i went and sat back down i'm sorry
i missed that detail conan i know you're
listening and
oh my gosh so jesse didn't know where
you were going i i thought for sure you
would have told her i did but i did it i
said it and did it all in one motion so
i'm going to tell them
i'm going to ask them something that i
could just ask you
and i think that if they thought about
it they would think about that yeah but
it's obvious that i really want to talk
to conan again so instead of asking you
my wife who i trust and i'm comfortable
with i'm going to get up and i'm going
to do something that puts me really out
on a limb here yeah in hopes that like i
will have a story on the ear biscuits
and maybe conan's wife will remember me
forever because she might see my wiener
well let's see i mean i knew that wasn't
gonna happen i had on very very
well fitting underwear there was no
there was there was no risk of exposure
there was no risk of exposure and the
fact is i had already tested it at my
seat
and i knew that nothing nothing peeked
out like i don't think something about
the pleating of these pants made it
where when you unzip them they
completely the flap remain completely
closed so i did have that point of
information i wouldn't have gone back
there and unzipped my pants in front of
conan and his wife if i had known that
something could pop out i knew that this
was kind of a bit but i was just i was
living in the moment it was it was
improvisational i feel like you know i
applaud you for that portion of the
presentation uh just putting yourself
out there without literally putting it
out there
uh and yeah it seems like the type of
thing i would have done
if i were drunk
i wasn't drunk i had a half a glass of
champagne okay well then
as we've established i'm six seven so
that's not a problem you don't
i had a little popcorn maybe it was
laced with something i think uh you know
i think you would i i think you would
have
i don't know there's no way there's no
explanation for this except like you
desperately wanted to make an impression
on conan he was like really try hard
well i think that that's the thing i've
been there i think well yeah you live i
know the feeling but i think that that's
hey don't listen that's the thing don't
listen don't drag me down why what
you're dragging me down
listen this is your story i'm giving you
the feedback
but i
i do not live in that world and i'm not
going to accept that okay right but
i have experienced it okay and i know
the feeling
but you
now know that feeling too that was the
thing that i was worried about is that
obviously i mean first of all when
you're conan o'brien
people come up and talk to you because
you're conan o'brien
and he has lived a life knowing that
that's the case
um and so it's no mystery that i'm going
up to tell him because this funny thing
happened to me and i've already talked
to him twice that night and i know
suzanne so it's like something funny
happens to you go to the other people
that you know at this place
yeah i'm going up there because he's
conan o'brien i think i would have
thought
i would have i'd like to think that i
would have thought
you know what at the after party
hopefully conan is there i'd love to
connect with him some more i knew he
wasn't going and this would oh you
already knew that i just know he's not
the kind of guy that's going to go the
other part and he didn't hmm okay so
you're right about that you had your one
shot and i was like and and also but i
would have used that as the excuse to
say yeah i'm not going to go this far so
again i applaud you for it i i can't
believe you did it yeah i'm going to
start doing more stuff like this
because it
what worked out
because it i mean i honestly think a big
part of it
is the fact
that i get to talk about it on the
podcast so it gives me a reason to to do
it but also
i honestly think
and this may apply to other people out
there
and i said it when i went up there
but i i'm forgetting pieces of the
conversation but when i when i s when i
said
i did this and i was like i don't know i
just haven't been in public for a long
time like this is the first this is the
first that's what i told them i mean in
another i think that that's true i do
believe that like if you were like if it
was me and i was seated a few rows back
you would have done that to me so
looking at it from another angle you're
not you aren't treating them any
differently than you would treated
somebody that you know
and that's kind of my approach just like
i don't care how famous you are uh i
want to talk to you because yes i do
but i'm also going to psych myself out
it's just like i'm going to treat you
just like i would if you were my you
know if you were my cousin or if you and
my my boy or if you were my
my friend
yeah i mean and so yeah i think in that
sense it's like hey we're
honestly just mixing it up
i think this is the key and you tell me
if this is true
i just did things without thinking about
them is that how you live not great
because that's that's how i found myself
in this situation i did not allow myself
to think a second time about the choice
just do it i just i told jesse i'm going
to talk to god and got him and just went
up there yeah it just happened and
okay so to put a button
fly three of them on this thing
can you see your fly open on the red
carpet photos no no like
if you're gonna and this is one of the
reasons that i didn't
ever suspect that it was open because
most of the time you can kind of feel
like you know what i'm saying like i'm
not talking like you feel a breeze right
i'm just saying that
if things are not secure down there with
a zipper a lot of times you know it
this this these pants apparently don't
even need a zipper like there it's
completely the the sides of the zipper
the teeth of the zipper are laying on
top of each other if they're not
intertwined so i picked the right pants
to be able to have this story have this
experience without actually getting into
an embarrassing situation so this could
be your thing you can look at all the
pictures on the red carpet the fly is
completely intact you could wear these
pants every time
keep them unzipped now they're navy's
knowing no one will see anything but you
can still go up to everyone
that's more famous than you and and have
that fly down conversation you know it's
a level of vulnerability that says you
know what i'm human and i'm here for you
if you need to have uh humorous
interaction and i was going to go talk
to i talked to greg daniels for a while
talking
i was done with that okay but i was
gonna go talk to the head of comedy at
amazon because he was there and i
thought oh this is an opportunity let's
connect with this guy yeah and uh and
then i was gonna tell him the zipper
story but
i got caught up in some other
conversations in the after party and by
the time i got around to going around
uh he was gone
so
missed opportunity
i think you did the best thing you could
have done
everything else is gravy
all right
now that now that we've fully
demonstrated that you are qualified to
give advice right let's do it
um but first we're going to talk a
little bit about stevie's podcast best
friend's back all right obviously you
listen to podcasts or at least one
particular podcast do you have room in
your life for a second
check out stevie's podcast well you got
our podcast where you got two best
friends who uh
never lost touch nope and then you've
got stevie's podcast where his two best
friends who did lose touch and are now
getting reacquainted via podcast i'm
very interested in what happens i mean
that's awesome yeah and you know i know
that i know stevie's a different person
than she was in high school so to ha to
be able to tell that to negin
and also to learn about negin i think
you know it's an there's a social
experiment aspect to this that uh is
potentially very fascinating and they're
just both delightful people therefore
you know stevie's delightful uh you know
her but and they're different the game
is she's delightful as well we met her
once when she came in to do like her
promotional photos and like she was
delightful shoot a couple of sketches to
promote the launch of the podcast so
check it out best friend's back all
right wherever you get your podcast
janet tweeted at us
uh in response to our prompt of hey
we're here to settle your ongoing
arguments
i'm very serious when i say that this is
one of the few things my boyfriend and i
legitimately argue about
if a chicken is alive is it raw
i say yes a live chicken is raw because
it's uncooked he says it's alive not raw
friends are 50 50 split we need a
definitive conclusion janet
this is a how does one arrive at this
argument that the most that's the most
interesting part to me is how do you get
to this point this is a conversation
i've never had hey look at that raw
chicken over there at the petting zoo
like
no that chick is not raw that chicken's
alive you have to be dead to be raw
how could their friends be 50 50 split
on this well i don't know
just speaking for
on janet's behalf don't you do it
i think that technically
an alive chicken is a raw chicken but
that is not a logical way to describe a
live chicken first if a chicken is alive
we say it's alive we don't say it's raw
but if you ask me the question is it
also raw i'll be like well i guess i'm
trying to think of an analogy where this
this is a this is a category this is a
misuse of categories well no it's just a
misunderstanding of the definition of
the word raw which implies if not
specifically states i can look it up if
i have to
that
a state of deadness
like raw is in the context of
being able to
eat it um
i think if you were to look at the
definition of raw it would say uncooked
meat
are we going to do this hold on like
your shoulder this your deltoid muscle
right now it is raw no it's not yes it
is that is it cooked cook
raw and cooked are opposites you know
what it has a one word definition
uncooked yeah that's what i'm saying
so when an egg comes out of a chicken or
red and pink okay perfect example when
an egg this is the distinction that
you're making is the fact that it's
attached to a living being but a cooked
egg and a raw egg if an egg comes out of
a chicken
it was raw when it was inside the
chicken and it's raw when it lands in
the nest the definition actually i was
wrong it says parentheses of food and
then it says uncooked so raw is a term
that applies to food
chickens are food no chickens are
animals dead chickens are food
i mean if you eat a live chicken you're
like some sort of weird i'm not saying
yes
i'm not saying it's moral but there are
i mean there are people eat things like
raw octopus
live oxy here i am live octopus i don't
support this
i'm not an advocate of eating live
things the exception doesn't make the
rule
here's the thing
we ate like the the raw tail can't wag
the dog here you ate alive you ate a raw
beetle
i'm not proud of that but you it was a
live beetle what i i'm saying we agree
and we disagree i'm saying that the
technical term raw means uncooked so yes
a live chicken is raw but that is like
only something that like a computer that
didn't understand humanity would say
it's an unnecessary distinction that's
secondary to the primary distinction of
it being alive and you know what
in that case it's misleading because
most people would associate rawness with
it with meat which was is detached and
dead so i agree with that but i'm just
saying that technically you're raw right
now and so am i
is any of you cooked right now
i don't want to say no because i don't
want to seem like i'm agreeing with it
so your whole body is raw right now
it's uncooked yes but it's not raw
no you're raw and live chickens are raw
now there's a venn diagram like if you
look up uncooked it's not just gonna say
raw like what's the definition of
uncooked
define
oh the definition is wrong
raw and cooked are
are opposites
you could cook somebody alive i i feel
you in the medieval times they cook
people you know what i'm saying it's a
punishment again do i believe in it no
but i'm not making a moral distinction
i'm saying that there were that you can
have something alive and cooked
i can cook your arm
oh
i could cook your arm you see you see
where janet's got us man
you cooking my arm you could put your
arm in an oven this is really i could
cook it and and i could eat it see what
you're embodying
but if you're like you're in the body
right is that dude's arm raw or cooked
to be like well i just cooked it that's
what this is about
before i cooked it do you want to be the
type of person
like janet who rhett is channeling right
now this is not a helpful thing janet my
advice not that you were asking for it
uh you were asking about your argument
my advice to you janet is that you
dropped this
this is not something it's only fun for
you yeah yeah this isn't this isn't a
hill to die on
you're not wrong but you're also not
right
you're arguing just just just to
entertain yourself
gotta admit it's pretty fun though
it's gonna it's gonna drive your
boyfriend away
hannah littlejohn tweeted at us
my partner and i have had the same
argument throughout our decade-long
relationship
is she a psychopath because she comes in
from work and will not change into pjs
until it's time for bed
i walk in the door and immediately start
the process of getting into comfy pjs so
hannah is saying that her partner is a
psychopath because
she doesn't wear pjs around the house
when she gets home from work
only when she's getting in the bed
i do not own pajamas uh i think for the
sake of this conversation it it includes
coming home from work
and putting on anything that is
demonstrably more comfortable like sweat
pants a t-shirt like slippers uh
yeah
well
i'm not saying slippers because i don't
want to bring into the whole show you
wear shoes in your own house thing i
don't want to go there that's not what
this is about what this is about is
changing out of how you're presenting
yourself to the work world in this case
or the outside world and then when you
come home you want to get into more
comfortable attire
that could that is so comfortable you
could in fact sleep in it that's how i'm
defining this argument i'm expanding the
scope a little bit because i think
that's much more
relatable to people if you because yeah
a lot of guys don't own pjs and i think
i want to include us in this experience
but are the pajamas raw
shut up
um okay dude so yeah what there's plenty
of times when it's like i'll come home
and i will i'll take off my jeans i mean
we don't dress we don't wear ties we
don't wear suits i don't wear a pantsuit
i don't wear heels to work you know
right and i acknowledge that like if
you're if the more buttoned up you are
because even though i'm not
when i come home i still have a desire
to get more comfortable especially after
pandemic link has been you know just
just walking around the house for a
couple of years right so i definitely
have this experience of
i come home and i'm like hot and sw hot
if i'm hot i might put on shorts or
usually i'll put on sweatpants and i'll
in uh
what
you get home and put shorts on if it
like when it's the times when it's
really hot
you know sometimes the asphalt melts
here in burbank because it's like 110
degrees
so i'm saying
in an extreme case i want to get
comfortable in that way but yeah my
default is oh i'm gonna sit down and
watch television i'm gonna put i'm gonna
put on my pajama pants
which i don't sleep in they're basically
like sweatpants hold on dude this is
you're all over the place what do you
what's your what's your argument because
i represent one end of the spectrum and
that end of the spectrum is
never in my entire adult life
i'm not counting as a kid because my
yeah yeah yeah just talk about people
made the decisions have i ever changed
clothes after getting home for any
reason other than
i have to then go to another event or
i'm going to go on like a walk you
you've never put on sweatpants you've
never gotten a more comfortable attire
like taking off your box of briefs and
putting on some boxers and some
sweatpants or some pajama pants never
like loungewear i don't do that well
you're missing out yeah but i i have two
reasons number one
just my disposition is not like i'm not
a comfort seeker right so it's i like
you know i i don't have i don't have a
blanket i don't
my couch isn't that comfortable you're a
masochist it looks cool and it's much
more about it looking cool than and
jesse's the same way like we're not
we're not seeking comfort a lot but and
i'm not that's just my personality
second thing
is um
that i and i think this is scientific
i think that
you actually need to signal to your body
that it's time to go to sleep and at
that point i just take my clothes off
and and and have underwear on and my and
then my body is like this is how we
sleep and now we're psychologically like
setting a cue to then move into the
sleep cycle as a side note do you change
your underwear before you go to bed no
huh i've gotten a bad rep for wearing
the same underwear for multiple days but
i never told
the caveat that like i wear i change
into pajama underwear every single night
yeah i mean if i went to sleep i wear
boxers if i take a shower at night i
wear briefs box of briefs during the day
i don't take a sh i don't have a shower
routine i take a shower at night every
three days
three to four days because i wash my
hair every three to four days and i have
to let it
dry at night
and then other other like five to six
days of the week i take a shower in the
mornings i don't have any routine okay
other than the fact that i do not change
clothes i don't i don't take my shoes
off you don't have you don't have skin
in this game i don't take my shoes off
until i go to bed interesting okay i
wear my shoes until 1am if i'm watching
tv i don't take my shoes off so i'm not
defending and i'm just saying that's
just does it cross my mind like ah my
feet hurt i need to take my shoes off
it's like that part of my brain never
developed so you don't okay because you
don't relate
i definitely relate but i disagree
so
for me
having
many days especially if i have a tough
day
again
it's like i i want to i seek that
comfort of like getting into something
more cozy and then i'm just gonna sit
down we're gonna we're gonna and this is
before dinner yes this is when i get
home from work there's if i have a
really bad pajama pants on before dinner
if i've had a really bad day
tip but then
typically
much more often
i would eat dinner and then it's like if
we're it's a couple hours before bedtime
we're going to sit down and watch
something on television survivor of
course
then i'm going to say before we do i got
to go get my topo chico and i'm going to
put on my boxers and pjs and i'm going
to get totally ready for this this
optimizes the comfort of this experience
and it's part of it for me
all of that being said i do not think
first of all being a psychopath has
nothing to do with this and i don't want
to use that language so and i'm leaving
that out of it but
i do i do not think it's a good idea to
make this a daily habit
because
from my perspective if i come home from
work every day and i immediately slip
into my most comfortable stuff
i'm not present it's like i'm presenting
my best self to the outside world but
then when i come home i'm just like
presenting
my just my most comfortable self which
is not my best self
not my most attractive self
to
uh christy
that's how i look at it you know what i
mean sexy pjs i mean i don't wear them
but i was gonna start wearing them they
look good i don't have sexy pjs
now
if hannah or
hannah's partner are coming home and
putting on sexy pjs then
my argument is gone because that doesn't
sound like the content no
i just think that you got
you even on the weekend
you know i like to put on clothes and
like
try to look like me look like the me
that i want to put out there like so
that i like to get a compliment from
christy oh i like that i like that
sweater oh you're wearing a sweater on
the weekend
yeah it's like i only wear sweats on the
weekend
and i'm not gonna fault you for that but
if you if you only wear
if you are only in pjs around your
partner
then you're not giving them the best
version of yourself and i think they're
you know it's like
you you want to you want to keep the
sizzle alive you know you want to keep
you want to keep that little round
going you know and that means putting
your best foot forward putting in the
work
now you don't have to do it constantly
you know i'm not even going to put a
ratio on it but
i think i want to put my best
best self out there for chrissy so she
remembers that this is
what i do is not just for other people
it's also for her
and for me
you know it affects my
how i feel about myself when i walk by a
mirror
you know
so i feel strongly that you got to take
your partner's interest
and attraction in mind and don't don't
save your best for other people
that's what this means to me
okay well i mean but if they're sexy pjs
that argument doesn't play that's true
but we know we know we know it's now to
me either way the scientific argument
applies that you may be screwing up your
sleep cycle by signaling by getting too
comfortable before you actually go to
sleep if you can like set the intention
and make the transition apparel wise
right around going to sleep you might
sleep better maybe i mean i'm reminded
of that like the flight of the concord
song business time where he's like he's
like but wednesday's the night that we
make love it's like and he's he makes a
joke about like oh when you're in your
sweatpants and you're that team building
t-shirt that you got at your
uh at the corporate event yeah whatever
the joke is you know it's like yeah
that's what they're making fun of
is just like okay you're not giving me
your best self here
yeah which you know they're on the bone
occasionally there's a part of you know
being in a long-term relationship once
you feel you don't feel the pressure but
i get your point that
there's a balance
uh this is an interesting one from from
kit
um
okay i asked my boyfriend
if he'd still love me if i was a worm
and his response is always no you'd be a
worm
he says he'd still take care of me until
the end of my wormy life but he wouldn't
love me whereas i tell him if he turned
into a worm i'd still love him and make
sure
he was living his warm life to the
fullest i just don't see why
me being a worm makes me incapable of
being loved
well it makes you incapable of giving
y'all crazy lots of type of love
this is wild uh
man now where are you the only way i can
relate to this is there's definitely
many times especially as a kid
when i thought to myself
if i accidentally turned into a bug of
some kind
how would i let my family know which is
why
you wrote that part of the i'm a
thoughtful guy rap where it was like i
think if i turn into an ant oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then you start spelling
out things right it says
yeah it's in that rap yeah that haunted
me that haunted me because i was like
how far could i get and then like
they would see it written and then see
an ant next to it and then they they
wouldn't just immediately think oh the
ant wrote this they have to see the ant
doing it but i ain't moved so slowly
that the chances that they see the
process unfold
i just think basically if you turn into
an ant you're screwed
no one's ever gonna know that you
happened you're gonna get killed but if
you didn't know and let's go back to the
worm thing unless you know earthworms
aren't
let's say it's an inchworm the cutest
worm of all okay you know it's like yeah
you would keep it in a terrarium and
you'd say yeah that used to be my
partner
no but it's not that is my partner that
used to be my partner now it's an
inchworm and i'm i'm loving it we have a
difference of opinion again you know i
think it is your partner yeah you're
right it is that is my partner is a worm
but my partner's now an inchworm do you
love it well yes
you know in a different way
you know it's i still love it i still
love it but we don't
you know we don't we don't get intimate
anymore
for example well we do but it's
different
it's it's it's only a bunch it's not
it's basically reduced to tickling i
barely feel it
wow um
i think that you can still communicate
you could come up with a communication
uh
method but i think one of the first
things well not the first thing but
ultimately you you'd want to use that
communication method to establish that
hey
i need human interaction
and i'm going to i'd like to find
another human partner i'd like for you
to find an inchworm partner here's the
thing and this is the thing i didn't
take into account with the whole ant
thing
is that when a person's
when a person turns into an animal
they don't retain the human intuition
and ability to process like they i think
that's baked in though no that dude
we've got to be scientific about this
when a person turns into a worm
they have the capacity of a worm
i don't know how the right i don't know
how there's no consciousness this is
translated from simple human to worm but
like
it's like you can't it's not your that's
not my partner anymore it's yeah then
it's now alright i can't take a nintendo
cartridge and stick it in a toaster you
know what i'm saying so if the brain is
the nintendo cartridge you stick it into
a toaster the toaster is like we do not
know what to do with this other than
melt it
so a worm is so simple that it's just
it's a special worm it has sentimental
value but the moment that a person turns
into a worm they no longer care about
anything other than what a worm can care
about and a worm doesn't give a [ __ ]
about a human
you know what i'm saying until they're
dead they try to eat them i think i
would put the i'd build a little
terrarium locket and i'd carry around
christy in a
let's make this personal inchworm
christie in a and a lock it around my
neck and even after she died i don't
know how long worms no not not after she
died no a dried insect i would i
wouldn't put in a locket no i would i i
want to enrich
uh inchworm christie's life by just
bringing her around with me like she can
hear conversation you know what i would
do of course you're saying that the worm
can't i would keep her at home after
jessie
worm jesse died
i put her into the bottom of the most
expensive tequila i could find
and then i would just drink her
okay that'd be it it could gather the
kids around but if she could communicate
that's when i think i would keep her in
a locket and try to enrich her life
as much as possible if it was like the
disney version but i would need to she
could still talk and everything of
course at that point we'd figure out
ways to make it work
right
yeah
uh solve that one
live your worm life to the
fullest do we want to get into this one
i'm kind of afraid of this one yeah why
not let's get into a serious one
okay
this is from lizzie
i'm moving in with my boyfriend of four
years this summer and my family does not
believe it's a good idea
for reference i was raised in the
christian even
evangelistic church how she puts it and
have since left any tips on how we can
amicably move through this disagreement
to hopefully land in at least a civil
place coming from a background of very
strong held beliefs on marriage and the
correct order of events i'd love to hear
your opinions
wow lizzy thanks for putting this out
there um
shoe i feel like i need to preface this
with you know
we haven't dealt with this with our own
kids
but
uh
you know they're getting older and this
will be something that i think that
we'll have to
we'll have to tackle but right now i'm
just going to be
i'm just going to be firing from the
tackle
we're going to have to i'm going to have
to wrap my mind around how i'm going to
approach this but i have like it's not
like christy and i sit around and talk
about what's gonna happen when lily says
that she wants to move in
but not marry her partner first like
what we haven't had that discussion it's
just not something that's come up in
conversation i mean we got enough that
we're parenting through right now it's
like that's the truth of parenting if
you try to look too far ahead you swerve
off the road right here you know so i'm
just making that point that like
i
i can't just sit down and say oh well
i've thought about this and this is what
we've concluded i'm shooting from the
hip
well i mean first of all the
are you
no i thought about it a little bit
okay
but have you and jesse talked about this
not this specifically but i i mean i
have a framework for how i think about
these okay so we should establish that
of yeah in the same way that lizzy's
alluding to here
yeah we've
we lived our entire lives thinking that
i you
i would never
shack up was the phrase with someone who
i wasn't married to
um
and then
when chris and i started dating yeah it
was never within the realm of
possibility to even consider that yeah
it was all everything was baked into the
experience of you get married
then you have sex and also move in
together
right which is kind of in that order
actually which is the point that
one thing to establish is that
i mean i'm sure there are some
exceptions but
in general
um those two things go hand in hand
believing that having pre-marital sex is
wrong
is the belief that
not living together until you get
married is predicated on right that's
that's really the only way that you get
there
there's not
again there could be exceptions but the
logic follows that we're not gonna live
together we're not going to cohabitate
because cohabitation
with romantic partners is probably also
involving sexual intercourse
until we can
you know by our own standards
be intimate with one another so so i
kind of want to set aside because i'm
i'm not an expert on like well i'm not
an expert on many things and nothing
that we talk about this podcast but
i'm definitely not an expert on or i
don't have like statistics
you know at the ready and i think a lot
of statistics people i mean i wrote an
article in the school paper
the nc state school paper because i was
i had i had an opinion column that's
right the nc state school paper and i
wrote a whole article about why
regardless of your religious tendencies
uh you shouldn't have pre-mental sex and
you shouldn't move in with your partner
because
uh
statistics showed that people who waited
to get married uh waited to have sex
when they got married and lived together
lived together longer or stayed together
more often and people who cohabitated
before marriage got divorced more often
now again
when you're creating a persuasive
argument in that way a lot of times it's
easy to find stats that kind of support
your thing but from a logical
perspective it kind of makes sense that
if you
move in and live together and then at
some point later you decide to get
married then you're kind of just sort of
stamping a uh
a legal commitment on top of something
that kind of already exists and maybe it
doesn't feel
i don't know i actually i don't know
what the statistics are so i don't even
want to get into what's actually a good
idea and what's a bad idea but i just to
uh
present the other argument which is
obviously
well there's so many benefits to
cohabitating right before you
make
a commitment
or if you view them as sacred vows
because you're uh
you know you're testing the waters
you're you're
if for something that's so huge like
let's commit the rest of our lives to
being together
uh
why don't we kind of ease into this a
little bit there's a reason there's a
shallow end to pools yeah and my point
is that that whole argument about which
is better is beside the point okay okay
like i'm not i'm not gonna tell you
what's better and what's not better i'm
not even gonna tell my kids because the
fact is is that if my kids don't believe
that they have to wait to have sex until
they get married which they don't
because they don't have a religious
framework where that would be the case
um i'm not saying they don't have a
sacred or you know view of sex i'm just
saying they don't have the christian
view of sexuality so
they're almost assuredly going to live
with somebody at some point a partner
whether they're married yet or not
i think the i think the thing in this
situation is that you've got parents
of adult children
who believe that they should be doing
something and continue to try to parent
you and give you advice
and this is especially difficult if
you're in a situation where you were
raised in a christian home and you were
kind of expected to live by christian
standards and now you're outside of that
and you don't actually live according to
those standards that's not how you make
decisions but your adult parents still
believe that this is what's best for you
and let's not
it's not this is not just a christian
phenomenon this is any sort of any sort
of phenomenon where
the parents think something
and there's a framework that the kids
do not follow i mean it's yeah this is
much bigger than christianity and my
take on that is that
i think it is important
to you know if you have a good
relationship with your parents and you
respect their wisdom
i think it you know they are another
outlet of
advice
and guidance to some degree
but once you are an adult
they're not your parents in the same way
they should not be parenting you anymore
this is a very difficult thing for
parents easier said than done very
difficult things
to do
but since you're not the parent and
you're the child asking this question i
think the thing is is that you have to
say
i'm going to make the decision that i
think is best for me and again that's
based on your own convictions and
research and whatever and i'm not going
to tell you what's right and what's
wrong in that
you made the decision that's best for
you
and then
your parents have you now i'm not saying
be disrespectful you you can be
respectful in the way that you
communicate that but i think you have to
set up a new mode which is i'm an adult
i do the things that i think are best
for me
you are my parent
but you're no longer parenting me you
did parent me in the past and now you're
just my mom and my dad we've got to set
up a boundary where you're no longer
telling me what i should do and what i
shouldn't do this is a really tough
thing to do but like yeah i think and
there's a tough way to
it's tough to broach that conversation i
mean she's saying hopefully we land in a
civil place where you can still have a
relationship i really hope that for you
lizzy that
um
that
you still are able to
have
a relationship
that is vibrant in other areas you know
and you just got this maybe there's a
sore spot but it's yeah i do think that
there's a way to
maybe
dis
disarm
the conversation
and have more of a connecting
um
to still have a connection
i think there's
open-ended questions that might can be
worked into a heartfelt conversation but
it might
this type of thing might require an
appointment hey i'd just love to sit
down and talk about this where we can
hear each other out
and
you know it's the type of thing where
you start to think about well can i
write a letter
to as like a preamble to a phone call or
an in-person conversation i don't
disagree with that where it's like
you're saying things like
i love you i i know you love me i know
you want what's best for me do you
expect me to do
everything that you the way you want me
to do it do you expect that to be how i
live my life i i'm maybe maybe you'd be
curious to know that answer
do
is your love
um
contingent on me
making certain decisions that you agree
with
you know i i think that's really what
this is about
and then
because what you don't want to get into
is you don't want to engage
in a way and this is a very difficult
thing for a child to do
of any age
it's for many of us it's very difficult
to get to a place where we can engage
with our parents
as if they don't have authority over us
anymore
but they don't especially in a way that
is still loving and respectful and
in has you have an engaging conversation
and not a
not a combative one and now this gets
very complicated if you are still
financially dependent on your parents or
if you work for your parents if your
parents are your boss
it gets really muddy
i'm not saying it can't work it can work
but in those situations it's really
important to establish boundaries that
hey dad you might be my boss
but you're not my dad anymore in the
sense that you don't parent me and the
moment that i you know when i yeah and i
wouldn't say it that way no no but but
you're not my dad anymore no no but i'm
not you but you being my dad me anymore
different way yeah i'm your employee
now
and i am your adult son or daughter
but i'm you so there's boundaries we're
just kind of talking about boundaries
and it sounds like what's happening is
that these parents may not again this is
a very difficult thing to let go of when
your kid
leaves this
this this way of thinking about things
and starts making decisions that don't
reflect your ideology and your religious
convictions
you of course it isn't just a difference
of opinion you actually think they're
going down a path of darkness to
destruction they're living according to
the world they're not doing what god
wants them to do anymore
right this is a i'm not saying this is
easy i will point out
on the
but on the other side of this
you
might jump to the conclusion
that you would be rejected if you go
through with something that your parents
disagree with
and
but it could go it could go either way
it could be a tragic separation where
there is rejection
but it could also you could also be
surprised that yes even though they've
taken a stance
on paper whenever their own child is
going through something it's an
opportunity for
your parents to
um
to adjust
yeah so i think they're
you know all hope is not lost even if
they've demonstrated
maybe even with an with an older sibling
or another sibling that um
is this is going to end this is going to
end poorly it's going to end in
rejection
maybe that's not the case so
uh but if it does end up that way it's
like
you have to
you've got to make sure that you're
protecting
your yourself and
interacting with that as healthily as
possible so then then the boundary
conversation is
is more about that how do i move forward
given that
this is the stance that they've taken
yeah because ultimately you can't engage
in a way
that indicates or suggests
that
what they think
and what they think you should do
is actually going to be the determining
factor and what you do do
that's the boundary though you're trying
to determine that that's the boundary
that you're setting up is that i'm an
adult i make decisions according to what
i think is right i will take your advice
about things but this is really you have
a religious perspective on this that i
no longer hold so i don't have the same
underlying motivation to make that
decision
and then
your parents have an opportunity to
respond to that because you know what
they've got room to grow as well like
you don't ever stop growing you never
start adjusting like you stop adjusting
like you said and so sometimes you have
to make the difficult decision
and then put the ball in their court to
make them have the mature response and
just because they're older doesn't mean
they'll have a mature response i'm not
saying and you shouldn't i'm not saying
you go into a situation like this like a
bull in a china shop and you just
are like screw it i'm going to do
exactly what i want and everybody can
deal with it you love your parents i
assume they love you you want it to be
amicable and you said that's what you
want
um i do think there is a way there but
if you get to a civil place because
you're sort of submitting to their
authority and letting that still be a
dynamic in your relationship
it's actually not going to be a healthy
thing long term
[Music]
good luck with that lizzy
thanks for sharing
hopefully that was helpful
okay
i mean do you do you want to hit another
one really quick i think here's a here's
a quick one to shut things down podrick
payne
tweeted to us if you call shotgun to a
car
but re-enter the house once it's called
are your shotgun privileges revoked yes
yes
yes because it
you if you go to a restaurant where you
order at the counter then you get a
number then you get a seat and then they
bring you the food or you wait at the
counter until you get the food and then
you get a seat
you do not come into the establishment
and then send somebody to get a seat
and then go up in order that's not the
system that ain't how this works and
that is not respectful to everyone else
there's a reason why there is a flow
there is a there's a right way to do it
you know i'm an enneagram one so
and an industrial engineer so to me
that's what this made me think of it
there's a system to call in shotgun and
you can't manipulate it
selfishly
i'm gonna go out here i'm gonna sit in
the car
i'm just gonna be in the car until
people come out
to need to go somewhere and then it's
like i'm i'm calling a shotgun matter of
fact i'm already in it but now that
you're all here i'm gonna go in the
house and make you wait for me
like
that's selfish well i know and i don't
even think and by the way it ain't worth
it i don't think podrick is necessarily
saying that this person sat in the car
no i think it's like it was hyperbole
it's like i could yell out the window as
you're all going to the car shotgun and
then just like stay in the house
first of all i believe that shotgun
can only be called once everyone begins
moving towards the vehicle i might even
go as far as to say you can't call
shotgun until you're outside but i won't
make that stipulation i mean some people
play uno that you keep drawing until you
can lay something down
that's torturous i don't know what the
actual rules are but you know what as a
family if you want to change the rules
as long as you all agree on them then
i'm i you
and when i enter to your house i'll play
uno by your rules i think that you need
to come up with that if but you need to
agree hey we all need to be exiting the
house that's what it says but re-enter
the house once it's called so i'm in the
in order to start in order you can't
call shotgun until when
and then until everyone's moving towards
the vehicle i i'm not asking you what
your rules are oh i'm telling podrick
i'm telling them i'm telling podrick
that he and his pod need to come up with
their rules
they probably need to be written they
probably need to be hammered onto the
front door
uh or i'm just talking about the
universal rules of shotgun that i feel
apply to all people once you're yeah you
can't
but it's this is simple you can't be
moving towards the car calling shotgun
just to go back in the house because i
demonstrated how that could
quickly move into just just being
manipulated to absurdity yeah
a person who calls shotgun has to
move with intention towards the physical
representation of shotgun which is being
in the passenger seat
after calling shotgun this isn't a time
for bathroom breaks etc
this is a one motion the spirit of
calling shotgun is that you're doing it
as an act of then moving into sitting in
the passenger seat you're being you're
kind of being a janet
right here you know
you're being the type of person if you
keep this up nobody's going to want to
ride with you anywhere who's janet
you know from earlier in this podcast oh
oh yeah
sorry janet
throwing you under the bus
you know i'm not going to say that i'm
going to get in my pjs link said that
janet i didn't say that you know um okay
i have a wreck real quick to wrap things
up
surprised to hear that you didn't know
about this website and that you also
weren't the one responsible for it
neil dot fun like my last name dot fun
so
i don't even i found this a long time
ago what it's just is some programmer
who has a series of games
so read off read off so like uh let's
settle this rocks ambient chaos 10 years
ago but like this the size of space
so you click on the size of space and
then just go like this and it's like oh
there's an astronaut there's a hubble
telescope oh i've seen this for like the
size of buildings for the size of uh
science fiction spaceships
so yeah it kind of creates this
timeline rocks oh there's just four
rocks um this is just nothing to do with
size sitting on a toilet
you've already solved wordle for the day
neil dot fun yeah neil dot fun i mean
it's just just a lot of just my name's
sake it's just a lot of fun to have it
neil.fun not a sponsor
i think you can like donate at the
bottom of it maybe
i think he says like
yeah buy me a coffee you click on buy me
a coffee oh no
oh you can just oh it's his first name
is neil
well too bad neil agarwal oh so i guess
he has like a patreon or something
but it's powered by buy me a coffee so
it's like his version of that i don't
really understand but neil dot fun neil
rhett's not gonna join your patreon but
he is promoting your oh just look at
this maybe other people paper you have a
piece of paper
and then you fold it once
it's the thickness of a human hair fold
it again
width of a grain of hand
boom boom width of a what a grain of
sand and look at this with the penny
width of a hummingbird and after like
a width of a volkswagen unfolded this
piece of paper now it's taller than the
eiffel tower whoa 25 folds
now it's it's deeper than the mariana
trench now it's bigger than the roads
that's just 30 volts just i mean there's
just so much fun to be had at neil dot
phone
all right
and there's so much fun to be had here
next week where we're going to speak at
you again but in the meantime hashtag
your biscuits let us know if you
disagree
with anything that we've said uh if
that's even possible
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]